oh
qu'est-ce que je suis tombé malade
attendez je vais présenter ça va super
bien je vous présente jamais de vous je
connais tous vos sens il remporte tous
les reproches étaient tous bien parce
qu'il attend juste gérer l'entrée coûte
- les caisses tu fais là ouais comme je
sais que tu as beaucoup de boulot 1
qu'il travaille comme un forcené ouais
j'ai préparé long à lire et prend son
temps oui on va prendre son temps
évidemment c'est parce que j'aurai comme
j'ai pas le temps moi c'est pour ça j'ai
retiré lire il me raconte derrière les
regarde tout le monde embarque pour
savoir ce qu'il en est exactement
il est très bien organisée en tout cas
sa tête pour radio londres j'ai quitté
si je vous ai déjà dit et l'appel du 18
juin comme je suis né le 18 juin ça me
fait kiffer c'est parti personne aucun
danger sa santé tout en testant que moi
moi je que je décris les questions
pourquoi que tu perds ton temps tu m'as
fait les questions en tout pendant évite
de me poser des questions à la con d'ici
le tromper csu s'est fait peur je me
lâche comme si j'étais pas au courant
des questions
ouais bon vous restait cinq minutes avec
nous ben je vous remercie japon benjam
elle qu'est ce que vous faites là
n'entend jamais avant chanel bon
génétique ben tu respires jamais bas
jamais là oui je fais que c'était
benziane elle
il s'entendait être à fond le jeu les
remettre dans l'ordre chanel on n'y va
jamais bonsoir vont sortir alors jamel
c'est vraiment un honneur un immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
le répéter la question parce que j'ai
pas ouais le panthéon c'est la fin mais
on lui
là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de choses
alors jamais c'est vraiment un honneur à
l'immense privilège d'avoir l'honneur de
vous avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
oui je vois ces risques est portée aux
arcs de triomphe pour réfléchir unaf où
tu sais plus si c'est pas moi c'est les
jo c'est les autres qui vont au moins
une certaine merveille extraordinaire
dont je suivis plus tu vois je suis pas
trop grand je fais je fais les choses
naturellement passé c'est le style c'est
le style c'est clair pourtant djamel
d'après le journal de mickey vous êtes
l'acteur préféré les enfants je tiens à
remercier les enfants en particulier
pour pour ça c'est vrai et ça s'est joué
ça s'est joué à ça un autre mois plus
tôt et c'est vrai qu'entre un chien
débile et un arabe callac la saison
préférée
jamel jamel c'est quoi vos plus grandes
qualités à part bien sûr la bogossité la
générosité la même minute elle s'est
étirée c'est très difficile de parler de
soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire la modestie
oui oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si
vous êtes de gens modestes ou très
modestes syfy de gaulle
alors est ce qu'ils vendent élite c'est
incroyable il faut vingt mille litres
par jour j'ai une énorme envie de 500000
la rigole c'est la première ne rentrent
moins son effigie et d'éviter comme des
années rampante de métro voici mois ci
s'est mis ses savoir faire mais aussi un
jour il a égalé un record qui s'appelle
le jamel debbouze comme enjeu qui vraie
magie
imagine tu imagines si philipp boy
prenez du pognon sur charles de gaulle
roissy charles de gaulle étoile station
charles de gaulle et où il faut il pour
s acheter plein de cravate bordeaux
alors jamel en 2002 d'après le figaro
vous êtes devenu l'acteur français le
mieux payé
oui mais d'ailleurs ça va causer pas mal
de temps je dois avouer
parce que maintenant j je vois venir
plein de nouveaux cousins qui sont en
galère d'oseille way qui débarque comme
ça il ya un mec qui est venu me voir en
disant je suis les filles se détend de
paris lui dis donc ça voudrait dire qui
serait mon frère elle m'a dit ouais je
suis ton frère je t'aime mon fils ne
rien dire du tout passé à cause du
figaro on est en pleine crise d'identité
alors oui effectivement il faut
j'aimerais remercier le figaro pour cet
article de bâtards bons djamel alors
c'est votre grand retour sur scène en
décembre vous êtes venus ici pour en
parler merci pas du tout irish
brouillons toute amitié
alors je vais pas venu faire de la promo
bobby c'est vrai que c'est mon grand
retour sur scène en même temps faire un
petit peu je joue ben attaquant
inch'allah à partir du 23 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier
c'est casino de paris le 3 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier au casino de paris
après j'enchaîne avec le bataclan 10 13
au 18 janvier après c'est vrai que
l'olympia arrive le 20 janvier jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive suis pas venu pour
en parler véritablement la question et
si vous voulez louer les places c'est à
la fnac ou virgin
le nouveau spectacle jamel el c'est pas
le sujet cet acte samassa paie jamais
elle 100% debbouze a est pourquoi je ne
fais jamais le double c'est une bonne
sinon je rappais différemment jamel vous
pouvez nous dire en deux mots de quoi ça
parle de moi à de vous c'est pour ça que
ça s'appelle djamel 100% debbouze en pas
de moi vous dire sans plusieurs mois
j'aurais fait j'aurais dit autre chose
mais là maintenant pas voilà enfin
pouvoir venir voir le spectre est pour
savoir de quoi ça parle uniquement de
moi pourquoi ça s'appelle déguisée de
construit site est à son paroxysme des
questions en utilisant longtemps c'est
c'est c'est chaud en prenant mon premier
spectacle je racontais un petit peu
j'étais très surpris de faire ce métier
avec tout ce que ça implique et émane de
là que je suis vraiment dedans c'est
encore plus étonnant c'est ce que je
raconte ce que je vais tâcher raconté
vous croyez que ça va intéresser les
gens
j'vais pas parce que tu crois que pour
décor de merde il intéresse les gens
complètement pour venir te voir avec la
démission il me demande si ça va
intéresser les gens tu crois pas
franchement sever et les pourris et ces
tags sais pas qui c'est ta grand-mère
café sénat a réalisé la musique les tags
d'ortie lui ils ont fusé d'ortie
musicaux fait les tags
il devait être il devait être sous juppé
s'est dit je vais te montrer ce que
c'est que de tailler exactement je vais
faire venir des amis à moi au grotesque
c'est que des tags en tueur mais
t'inquiète pas encore encore une
question que ceux de bull maintenant que
vous avez un succès énorme que vous
croulez sous les sollicitations
vous pouvez nous dire est ce que je suis
c'est se tromper tu vois qu'il veut
battre en empêcher tu vois j'ai toujours
profondément sadique
tu dois tu dois être heureux temps
scolaire qui doit être fait et ans a dit
si tu essaies tu t'es pas obligée de me
poser la question est ce que si c'est
trop je ne peux pas te répondre a fait
quelque chose je préfère me taire ma
mère regarde l'émission un peu c'est
ramadan au total jamel
est-ce que tant qu'il est là c'est
incroyable de la voirie va revenir au
mois de février
philippe de gaulle mais est-ce que tu as
une question à lui poser monsieur
philippe de gaulle
vous êtes donc le fils forcément de
charles est ce que il aimer le rap est
ce qu'ils connaissaient tupac shakur
ovidie small par exemple de son temps
comme ça et il lui arrive et que dans
ces deux parties rentrer ou pas
reprocher non mais regardez les jambes
mais jamais jamais voulait pris en flag
dans votre salon en train de ronger les
sangs est épuisé il était très strict et
leurs cartes postales non c'est pas de
femmes comme c'était pas dans son talent
il préférait regarder ceux dont le
talent mais parce qu'on voit les chefs
d'état en aide peu mon point de vue en
tout cas qui je suis pas chef d'état et
que de mon état je me dis que y
ils sont toujours obligés tout le temps
toute leur vie deck sérieux oui sans
jouer le sérieux mais ça les empêche pas
de s'amuser parfois mais c'est un jeu
sans rire à tout moment quand même s'ils
sont pas sourire et qu'on les voit pas
rire ya des choses qui les amuse
ils nagent avec l'exigence du frère il
et il était plutôt gentil plus tôt et où
les sages toucher les gens qui il était
sage mais là ils avaient affaire à
vocaux difficulté forcément ils
n'avaient pas que ça ferme c'est réparé
on l'avait fait venir pour sa voix
superbe allée le chercher c'est allé le
chercher dans tout ça fait comme on dit
chez moi
merci beaucoup merci vive de gaulle
ball mon père philippe devaux
l'entretien avec michel tauriac
il
moi
changer
il va revenir en février pour le
deuxième tome alors le spectacle donc
c'est d'abord au casino de paris c'est
ça en jette au bataclan ensuite à
olympia c'est ça carla et c'est avec
kader aoun toujours tu l'écris avec
kader et c'est kader qui fait la mise en
scène toujours cela ne change pas une
équipe qui gagne nos fesses à son
premier spectacle c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne et qu'on a pris beaucoup de
plaisir et je vois pas pourquoi je
changerai mon algérienne pour rien ne
bouge la lâche pas je la kiffe raider si
tu m'écoutes change rien car si tu
m'écoutes changerait de la chance de
travailler avec kader aoun
ces deux là sont ceux ci travaillent et
canal très content pour kader a beaucoup
de choses sérieuses avec est-ce que ce
que j'aime beaucoup chez lui c'est que
il vient du des mêmes droits que moi et
vient de bobigny et et à la différence
de moi il a fait sciences po et c'est ce
qui lui permet d'avoir un certain recul
sur bobigny et je suis riche de 7 de son
expérience à chaque fois il me fait
profiter de tout ce qu'il connaît et il
a lu plein de bouquins que j'ai pas eu
forcément donc il me fait la syntaxe
tout le temps il a lu tous les livres il
a vu tous les films et toutes les
émissions c'est réglé c'est comme si
j'avais fait sciences po quelque part
tu as vu ce que m'a offert lé n ce gars
le problème c'est pour l'arrêter ap
voilà c'est hélène ségara qui tend à
faire ça oui elle m'a offert aussi des
du foie gras mais le foie gras était pas
là et devrait s'inspirer du rat musqué
frévent de plus de 10
on va en parler à orlando
élaborée
la wii
et maintenant c'est slash jeté là non
oui je n'aime que si michalak
et
hé les gars là comment elle est belle
c'est vrai on peut pas dire le contraire
on doit observer tous les deux vous avez
des supers dit ouais à échelle que tu
peux pas dire des trucs comme ça gratuit
tu me tues mais tu me dises à moi
forcément après je vais avoir envie
qu'il se passe quelque chose entre nous
ouais c'est ça il est depuis longtemps
j'ai à chaque fois qu'on se voit sur un
plateau de télé michèle laroque
on se dit qu'on va se revoir sans les
caméras après toi tu pars los angeles
toutes mes émissions se voit pas alors
si on n'était pas la télé tu me dirais
tu où tu me direz vous non mais je t'ai
dit tu es ce que si on n'était pas la
télé tu serais aussi heureuse de voir
que ce soir c'est déjà arrivé
oui oui mais pas assez je trouve est ce
que tu te serais fait aussi belle si on
n'était pas la télé pour me voir mais
j'ai toujours vu moi aussi restent en
lice entre le soleil
c'est pas la politique qui quitte ce
serait laisser faire par exemple tu
ferais quoi s'en était pas l'aider on
irait boire un verre
sais tu que des plats l'endroit si on
perd c'est vrai voilà la bouteille tfou
toi tu crois que tu vas tu faire à
l'envers à elle connaît par coeur ça
fait 2 30 g merdier sur ses lèvres
est-ce que sur le départ et à kehl et
michel tu me dirait vraiment ce que tu
penses le mois oui moi je connais un
thierry ardisson que j'adore parce qu'on
est double ouais et que et que et avec
beaucoup de sensibilité de gentillesse
et d'intelligence et je le pense et qui
a un autre et ardisson quand on connaît
pas que j'aie jamais rencontré vraiment
dont parfois on en parle parfois et
j'espère que celui je connais ma
complètement thomas y voilà jack un
tueur dix ans je n'étais pas la télé je
pourrais te je pourrais être dragués
variété majesty sérieuse alors choisi
par la télé on parlait de ton actu tu
crois non on n'en parlerait pas en fait
on va en parler parce qu'on est énoncé
ce qui t intéresse à se cacher tu ne
devrais alors non j'aime bien sûr en
arrivant je pense que je te demanderai
de trois questions
on me donne in quoi
à l'école il croit que les mecs qu'ils
ont décidé web et du haut de mes
questions est-ce que ça va intéresser le
public mon spectacle
oui tu vas voir qu'après cette émission
pour décor il va intéresser le tout
djamel michel non mais non mais toi fais
comme si de rien n'était vous continuez
vos émissions allez on y va on a un
problème il a peint caméra oui quatre
élus je pense qu'à un moment de ma veste
et qu'il l'a pas fait nous battons sur
les rend bien il revient elle a [ __ ]
l'oeil de freestyle c'est le maître de
blanc dit tu sais moi je suis désolé
s'est quittés potes qui sont avec toi la
ddt reprises jusque là essentiellement
alors messieurs michel team à son égard
que dalger bangui avec d'armandie tron
dany boon a pas qu'on va beaucoup
s'amuser et dany boon tu l'as tu l'as vu
sept ans sinon la dernière fois que je
les ai vus j'ai pas vu sa pièce mais je
vais y aller mais alors passé il était
en vacances à megève il a aidé voilà il
avait l'air en forme
il s'est remis de sa séparation d'avec
qui dit parce qu'elle était la semaine
dernière bell a l'air de s'être bien
remise mais je crois que la situation
lui aussi ce rôle là
mad men série ama 2004 il me demande si
on peut aller chercher une baisse de
secours chez moi catherine
mais si je donne le code comme je fais
une autre émission chez moi tu donnes le
club catherine c'est mort dommage que
philippe de gaulle soit parti jonage
bavard comme on irait qui fait faire
philippe de gaulle nous sur la seule
aire de blessures bien donc
judith godrèche était là la semaine
dernière elle avait l'air d'avoir assez
bien appris sa séparation d'avec dany
boon ça ça allait nettement mieux joué
et gagné ça va aussi
j'ai l'impression non alors il ya aussi
un coffret qui va sortir avec une scène
et ses 106 me voilà avec pierre il se
fait engueuler non non ça va les caméras
les caméras oui compétition avec itsm
ils se sont tenus là c'est à la saga
complète tu penses tu fais quoi michel
quand tu pars tout le temps à los
angeles comme ça alors moi je prépare un
film j'ai acheté les droits d'un livre
qui s'appelle fitch caroline bon groupe
je le connais voilà c'est bien sûr et on
voudrait faire un film inspiré de ce
livre à ce fait un film sauvez le pitch
peut-être robert tu vas venir le pitch
est ici un acte obligatoire
alors je n'étais pas la télé ce que je
pourrais couper les moments où j'ai
l'air con quand je te regarde comme ça
jamais l'air con c'est vrai oui c'est
une idée que tu te fais je n'ai pas la
télé tu dirais quoi du décor de cette
émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment
moi je suis sincère je trouve que kate
des tests en france en titre et de
suspens car la petite rue je vais la
signer way up
ouais
à son bord
un gars comme un valet est-ce que
valérie peut venir là valérie sa part
commence sur la peau parfois sa part
finalement way soit là je suis comme ça
pour un long moment
est ce qu'on peut faire valérie un des
lingettes des logettes la revient avec
des lingettes valérie je continue
interview de madame larocque se termine
ici alors je n'étais pas la télé tu
ferais quoi comme problème à me raconter
je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu dans le ciel
les arts et cetera que les gens qui
étaient un peu fragiles sont allées très
très très mal oui et j'avais plein de
coups de fil 200 qui allait mal et ça
m'a vraiment inquiété et voilà c'est ça
les problèmes en laisser des gens flippe
un peu lancement vachement c'est la
période de l'année sinon plus une époque
un petit peu c'est ça ouais ouais
et puis comme je suis maintenant entre
les deux c'est quand je reviens je me
sens plus ces choses parce que j'ai pas
subis tu vois toutes les pressions ici
et je trouve que parfois c'est très
lourd et je trouve que les gens sont
plus flipper en france aux états unis en
france c'est différent ils sont très
fines avec vous je chante mais à cause
de bushmills non mais les gens n'ont
plus le moral
il ya eu quelque chose aurait déduit je
trouve un truc les gens ont pu la pêche
non qu'est ce qui se passe là bas
hiromi irp 1 4 il est dans la loge vip
d'accord je viens d'assister une chose
ils attendirent ici j'espère que t'as
pas mis un costume neuf non c'est oui
mais pas à mourir un jouet styrie
une tâche estime pas mais pas moi
il s'est enfui il s'est enfui à le jamel
dia si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser jamel
debbouze personne n'a jamais su est
agile questions à poser à tirer tirer
qui m'attend je t'entends john e comment
tu peux mettre des photos pareil jallieu
quoi qu'il ait acquis mais david valider
la cua rien mauvaise mise sur cette
photo mais c'est le style de la photo
djamel d'apprendre à dire que mon
spectacle n'est pas intéressant poussons
la télévision même chanté par la
télévision
est ce que tu me parlerait quand même de
gerpinnes teurs ouais ouais c'est bien
c'est bien content pour lui parce que
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
de talent et j'adore le spectacle fait
les gens mais ce martèlement et voilà
quoi c'est c'est quelque chose dont il a
été longtemps un to lose it arrivée à
paris là tout c'est leur lui a pas
encore la pression et de jouer sans
pression qui nous avons exactement et il
y croit vraiment et je trouve que c'est
bien et alors il est venu ici nous
parler de son nouveau spectacle qui
s'appelle on tire bien sûr les lapins au
théâtre fontaine tu la ville évidemment
rêver ça fait marrer cmh il adore et ma
mère là dedans tu vois c'est un peu
touché les ratios bientôt mais enfin su
le faire bien géant fincher on tire bien
sûr les atteint